good afternoon
i uh
i promised when i got elected i'd always
give it to you straight from the
shoulder
the good the bad the truth
so as we head into christmas weekend i
want to answer your questions about the
rising number of coveted cases code 19
cases
and i want to start by acknowledging how
tired
worried and frustrated i know you are
i know how you're feeling for many of
you this will be the first or even the
second christmas
where you look across the table be an
empty kitchen chair there
tens of millions have gotten sick
we've all experienced upheaval in our
lives
but while covet has been
a tough adversary we've shown that we're
tougher
tougher because we have the power of
science and vaccines
that prevent illness and save lives
and tougher because of our resolve so
that let me answer some questions
that lay uh
out the steps the vice president and i
are taking prepare for the rising number
of cases experts tell us
we can expect in the weeks ahead first
how concerned should you be about
omicron
which is now the dominant variant in
this country and it happens so quickly
the answer is straightforward
if you're not fully vaccinated
you have good reason to be concerned
you're at a high risk of getting sick
and if you get sick you're likely to
spread it to others including friends
and family
and the unvaccinated have a
significantly higher risk of ending up
in the hospital
or even dying
almost everyone who has died from
coca-19 in the past many months
has been
unvaccinated
unvaccinated
if you're wrong
among the majority of americans who are
fully vaccinated and especially if
you've gotten the booster shot that
third shot
you're much you have much much less
reason to worry
you have a high degree of protection
against severe illness
because omicron spreads so easily
we'll see some fully vaccinated people
get cold
potentially in large numbers
there'll be positive cases in every
office
even here in the white house among the
unba among the vaccinated among the
vaccination
from omaha
but these cases are highly unlikely to
lead to serious numbness
vaccinated people who get common
may get ill
but they're protected
from severe illness and death
that's why you should still remain
vigilant
according to our doctors
even if you're fully vaccinated you
should wear a mask
when indoors and in public settings
wearing a mask provides extra protection
for you and those around you and i know
some americans are wondering
if you can safely celebrate the holidays
with your family and friends
the answer is yes you can
if you and those who celebrate with are
vaccinated particularly if you've gotten
your booster shot
if you are vaccinated and follow the
precautions that we all know well
you should feel comfortable celebrating
christmas and the holidays as you
planned it
you know you've done the right thing you
can enjoy the holiday season
and thanks to the progress on
vaccinations this fall
we've gone from nearly 90 million adults
in july who have not even started the
vaccination process
to fewer than 40 million today
still too many
down from 90 to 40.
all these people who have not been
vaccinated
you have an obligation to yourselves
to your family and quite frankly i
normally criticize for this to your
country
get vaccinated now it's free
it's convenient
i promise you it saves lives
and i honestly gotta believe it's your
patriotic duty
another question
folks are asking is what can you do to
make yourself and your family feel safer
and be safer
the answer is simple
get your booster shot
wear a mask
our doctors have made it clear booster
shots provide the strongest of
protections unfortunately
we still have tens of millions of people
who are eligible for the booster shot
who have not yet gotten i've gotten the
first two shots
they've not gotten the booster
folks the booster shots are free
and widely available
over 60 million americans
including 62 percent of eligible seniors
our most vulnerable group have gotten
their booster shots i got my booster
shot
as soon as they were available
and just the other day former president
trump announced he had gotten his
booster shot
maybe one of the few things he and i
agree on
people with booster shots are highly
protected
join them join us
it's been six months or more since my
second shot
if it's been six months or more for your
second shot when i got my booster you
can get yours today you've been six
months or more since your second shot
another question that folks are asking
is are we going back to march 2020 not
just last march 2021
but march 2020 when the pandemic first
hit
and that's what i keep getting asked the
answer is absolutely no
no
there are three big differences between
then and now
one
number one first one
more than 200 million americans have
been fully vaccinated
in march
2020
no one was fully vaccinated
what that means is today
as cases a case of covert 19 for fully
vaccinated and boosted person will most
likely mean no symptoms or mild ones
similar to the common respiratory
viruses
over 200 million americans should have a
peace of mind that they did not have in
march of 2020
they're protected
from hospitalization and are protected
from death
second point
we're prepared today for what's coming
in march of 2020 we were not ready
today we spot tile enough we stockpiled
enough gowns mass and ventilators
to deal with the surge of
hospitalizations among the unvaccinated
today we're ready
and as i'll explain in a few minutes
we're going to be reinforcing our
hospitals helping them
number three
we know a lot more today than we did
back in march of 2020.
for example
last year we thought the only way to
keep your children safe was to close
close our schools
today we know more and we have more
resources to keep those schools open
we you can get five to 11 year olds
vaccinated
a tool we didn't have until last month
today
we don't have to shut down schools
because of the case of covert 19.
now if a student tests positive other
students can take the test and stay in
the classroom if they're not infected
rather than closing the whole school or
having a quarantine
we can keep our k-12 schools open
that's exactly what we should be doing
so folks let me summarize
we should all be concerned about omicron
but not panicked
if you're fully vaccinated and
especially if you got your booster shot
you are highly protected
if you're unvaccinated
you're at a higher risk of being
severely ill from coca-19 getting
hospitalized and even dying
so the best thing to do is get fully
vaccinated and get your booster shot
and no this is not march of 2020.
200 million people are fully
vaccinated we're prepared
we know more you just have to stay
focused
so that's where we stand
now let me tell you about the additional
steps i'm ordering today to take on what
is coming i know you've heard a lot of
this in the news already this morning
three weeks ago
i laid out a covet 19 action plan for
this winter
and prepared us for this moment
today
we're making the plan even stronger
first
we're setting up our vaccination and
booster efforts we're stepping it up
significantly
in the past two weeks we've seen the
highest vaccination rates since last
spring
and we aren't as vaccinated as a country
as we should be though
that's why we have added 10 000 new
vaccination sites
on top of the 80 000 sites that are
already we have already had in place
and even more will open in january
i know there's some parts of this
country where people are very eager to
get their booster
where it's harder to get an appointment
excuse me
so starting this week
i'll be deploying hundreds more
vaccinators
and more sites to help get the booster
shots in people's arms
i've ordered fema the federal emergency
management agency
to stand up new pop-up vaccination
clinics
all across the country
where you can get that booster shot
we've opened
excuse me open fema vaccination sites in
washington state and new mexico
recently as cases have increased
and today i'm directing fema to stand up
new sites in areas where there is a high
demand
these steps are going to help us add
more
more and more booster appointments and
over the just over the next few weeks
i also want to say a word to parents
if your children are not vaccinated
please get them vaccinated
if you're a parent understandably who
waited
to see how the first shots went with
other kids before getting your own kid
vaccinated you can stop waiting
six million children in our country ages
five to eleven are vaccinated
get your children protected today now
for those parents out there who have a
child that's too young to be vaccinated
that is under the age of five
i know this can still be a scary time
but one thing
one thing you can and must do
while we await vaccines for children
under five
get yourself fully vaccinated and
boosted
as well as those around you
your children your caregivers your
siblings
it's critical to mask up in public
indoor places
we know that our youngest children
have only rarely been impacted by
serious covert case uh coca-19 cases
but they can be further predicted if
they're surrounded by a vaccinated
people
and again to folks who are not
vaccinated you might think you're
putting only yourself at risk
but it's your choice
your choice is not just a choice about
you
it affects other people you're putting
other people at risk
your loved ones your friends neighbors
strangers you're running
and your choice can be the difference
between life or death
the longer the virus is around
the more likely variants form
it may be deadlier than the ones that
have come before
let me say again and again and again and
again
please get vaccinated
it's the only responsible thing to do
those who are not vaccinated or causing
hospitals to over
run become overrun again
i just spoke to the governor of new york
every covet 19 hospital means someone
with a heart attack cancer other serious
illness may not get that bed and that
life-saving care they need in the
hospital
look let me give it to you straight
again
omicron is serious potentially deadly
business for unvaccinated people
let me be clear
thanks to the prior administration and
our scientific community america is one
of the first countries to get the
vaccine
thanks to my administration and the hard
work of americans
we led a rollout made america among the
world leaders in getting shots and arms
what uptakes slowed this summer as
vaccine resistance among some heart
look the unvaccinated are responsible
for their own choices
but those choices have been fueled by
dangerous misinformation on cable tv and
social media
you know these companies and
personalities are making money
by peddling lies and allowing
misinformation that can kill their own
customers and their own supporters
it's wrong
it's immoral
i call on the purveyors of these lies
and misinformation to stop it
stop it now
one of the other things that we know
that has to be done is more testing
because omicron spreads easily
especially among the unvaccinated it's
critically important that we know who's
infected
that means we need more testing
on that score we're now where we should
be
yes we have over 20 000 free testing
cells
yes we've used the defense production
act and spent three billion dollars
to greatly expand the number of at-home
tests available for purchase online and
at your local pharmacy and yes
we made sure insurance covers the pcr
tests you get in the hospital or at your
doctor's office
but starting next month
private insurance will all cover also
cover at home testing
so you can order a test online and get
reimbursed
we're providing access to free at-home
tests for those who may have insurance
as well may not have insurance i should
say as well
but it's not enough
we have to do more
we have to do better and we will
starting this week
the federal government will set up
emergency testing sites
in areas that need additional testing
capacity
before christmas
the first several of these federal
testing sites will be up and running in
new york city
with many more to come
this free testing is going to help
reduce the waiting lines
the time you have to stand there
and sometimes it's hour more we're going
to continue to add federal testing sites
where needed so if you want an immediate
test
to be a place where you can go get it
we also need to do better with at-home
testing so i'm announcing today the
federal government will purchase one
half billion
that's not million billion with a b
additional at-home rapid test with
delivery starting in january
we'll be getting these tests to
americans for free
we'll have websites where you can get
them delivered to your home
we've arranged for it to be easier for
you to find a free copa testing site
near you on google
just enter
covert test near me
the google search bar
and you can find a number of different
locations nearby where you can get
tested
we're going to continue to use the
defense production act
as we did earlier this month to make
sure we're producing as many tests and
as quickly as possible
the bottom line
is it's a lot better than it was
we're taking even more steps to make it
easier to get tested and get tested for
free
next
we're preparing hospitals for what's
coming
those 40 unvaccinated adults
have a good chance of getting coca-19
and some of you will get very sick
model main hospital is going to get
extremely stressed
extremely stressed in you
both in terms of equipment
as well as personnel to care for those
who get sick
that's why my administration
has stockpiled and pre-positioned
millions of gowns
gloves
masks and ventilators it's called a ppp
we're ready to send them immediately to
any state that needs more in addition
i've directed the pentagon to mobilize
an additional 1 000 troops
to be deployed to help staff local
hospitals and expand capacity
that's 1 000 military doctors nurses and
medics
who've already started moving military
excuse me medical age
they've already landed in wisconsin
indiana this week
this is on top of 300 federal medical
medical personnel that are now on the
ground
having deployed since we learned about
overcrowding
look
while we know staffing is the biggest
need for hospitals
some may need more beds as well
we're prepared
i've directed fema to activate the
national response center and begin
deploying teams now to provide
additional hospital events
we began to construct emergency
capacities near hospitals in parking
garages and nearby buildings to be ready
if needed
and the
federal government is paying for all of
this
period all of it
further
fema will deploy hundreds of ambulances
and ems crews so that if
one hospital fills up we can transport
patients to beds elsewhere
this week
we'll send dozens of ambulances to new
york and maine because of because the
covert is spreading very rapidly
to help transport patients
our doctors nurses hospital staffs have
gone above and beyond during the
spending
the strain of stress is real i really
mean it it's real
and we'll have their backs though
we have to let them know we have their
backs
finally
we're making sure the covet 19 no longer
closes businesses or schools
last week
the federal court reinstated my
administration's vaccination or test
the vaccination of test rule for
businesses with more than 100 employees
the law requires employers with 100 and
more employees to protect their workers
who are on-site and indoors with the
requirement that they be vaccinated or
tested each week or go home
these rules are going to keep workers
safe and keep workers safe will help
keep businesses open
people are vaccinated or tested
they're much less likely to get sick and
less likely to spread into others
customers are more likely to come in and
shop
because they know it's a safe
environment
i know vaccination requirements are not
popular
for many
not even popular for those who are
anxious to get them
my administration has put them in place
not to control your life but to save
your life
in the lives of others
where four hundred thousand americans
died from covert this calendar year
and almost all
were unvaccinated almost all were
preventable
rule is legal effective
it's going to save thousands of american
lives
must also keep our k-12 schools open
look the science is clear
and overwhelming
we know how to keep our kids safe in
covet 19 school
k through 12 schools should be open
and that safety is increased if schools
require all adults
who work in the schools to get
vaccinated
and take the safety measure that the cdc
is recommending including masking
i got congress to pass
billions of dollars in school
improvements ventilation and social
distances
school should be safer
than ever
from covert 19.
and just friday the cdc issued a test to
stay guidelines so schools can stay open
and kids can stay in class even if a
classmate test positive
covert 19 is scary but the science is
clear
children are safe and
as safe in schools they're already
placed assuming the appropriate
precautions have been taken and they've
already been funded
let me close with this
i know you're tired
i really mean this and i know you're
frustrated
we all want this to be over
but we're still in it
this is a critical moment
we also have more tools we've ever had
before
we're ready
we'll get through this
as we head into the holidays
i want us to all keep the faith
want to sincerely thank you for your
perseverance your courage your countless
acts of kindness love and sacrifice
during these last two years
throughout our history
we've been tested as a people and as a
nation
through war and turmoil
we'd ask whether we'd be safe
whether it be okay
whether we get back to who we are
i've always endured because remember
there's no challenge too big for america
i mean this from the bottom of heart no
challenge
we've come through better and stronger
because we stay together
as the united states of america
that's what we have to keep doing today
we can do this together
i guarantee you
may god bless you all
and may god protect our troops
and
happy holidays
you said we have to do better but public
health officials have been saying for
months you need to surge rapid tests for
just this moment is it a failure that
you don't have an adequate amount of
tasks for everyone to be able to get one
if they need one right now no it's not
because covet
is
spreading so rapidly you notice
it just it just happened almost
overnight just the last month
no
but the alarm going off i don't think
anybody
anticipated that this was going to be as
rapidly spreading as it did
and so the question is we have a lot of
people who have access
to tests who could order them could
could have their insurance paid for them
etc but it also and all of a sudden it
was like everybody rushed to the counter
it was a big big rush
and i knew that was coming so what i
tried to do is meet with the companies
and use the defense production act to
get a half a billion more tests and
figure out how to get them to their
homes get them on the shelves in the
store i mean so that that's what it's
all about yes mr president what's your
message to americans who are trying to
get tested now and who are not able to
get tested and who are wondering what
took so long to ramp up testing come on
what took so long
i'm hearing that from people who are
trying to get tested now before the
holidays well
what took so long didn't take long at
all
what happened was
the omicron virus spread even more
rapidly than anybody thought if i told
you
four weeks ago that this would spread by
a day-to-day basis
it would spread by 50 100 200 500
i think you would have looked to me and
said biden what are you drinking
but that's what it did
now we don't know what's going to happen
from here
it looks there there's some evidence
that in south africa where a lot of this
started that it's dropping off quickly
too we don't know
but i do know that we're not going to be
in a position like i said when we
remember we were having a problem with
masking gowns and the like
i said i promise you remember the
criticism i got questions from some of
you why are you still paying for all
these masking gowns why are you
stockpiling this
because we don't know it turns out we're
going to meet
in the back and then
does that work sir and will you reverse
the travel ban now that omicron's so
prevalent here in the u.s i'm
considering the version i'm going to
talk with my team in the next couple
days um look remember why i said we put
the travel ban on
is to see how much time we had before it
hit here so we could begin to decide
what we needed by looking at what's
happening in other countries
and but we're past that now
and so
uh it's something that is being raised
with me by the docs and i'll have an
answer for that soon
about the importance of keeping your
word of trust do you believe senator
manchin kept his word to you and how do
you rebuild trust with progressives in
your party to advance their legislation
enough
you know i told you before you've heard
me say this before
some people
think maybe i'm not irish because i
don't hold a grudge
look i want to get things done i still
think there's a possibility of being a
buildback better done what i don't want
to do is get into and joe went on tv
today and
uh not was tv or not i'm told he was
speaking to
the liberal caucus in the house and said
joe biden did this
and so look i'm not i'm not looking for
let me say something
you saw what happened yesterday
all the talk about how my build back
better plan was to increase inflation
causes debts
what happened goldman sachs another said
if we don't pass bill back better we're
in trouble because it's going to grow
the economy without it we're not going
to grow
and what happened
stock prices went way down
it took a real dip
if you take a look
i wasn't everybody thinks because i
quoted 17 nobel laureates saying this is
going to help inflation think about it
in terms of you're a hard-working person
and you're making 60 grand if you're
alone or a mom just on their own or if
you're making 80 grand mom and dad 90
grand like a lot of people do
and you're worried about inflation you
should be worried about because it's a
devastating thing for people who are
working class and middle class folks
it really hurts where is most of the
cost now the cost is finding in gasoline
even though i put i was able to bring it
down 12 cents a gallon will come down
more i believe
we talked about what the cost of food
prices going up etcetera
but look what's in
what does them go back better
child care you can reduce it by up to 70
percent that'll be the difference
between 20 million women who go on back
in the workforce being able to go back
if you pass it we're talking about we're
talking about healthcare
insulin and essentially we got we got
200 000 kids with type 1 diabetes
you know what it's costing it costs
somewhere between 10 cents and 10 to
come up with the formula okay a while
ago
right
you know what it's costing on average
five hundred and sixty dollars over six
hundred forty dollars a month
up to a thousand dollars a month
what do you do
if you're a mom and a dad
working with minimum wage busting your
neck you look at your kid
and you know if you don't get that
vaccine for that excuse me if you don't
get that drug for him if you don't get
that that that be able to take that
what happens
well i can go in a coma maybe die
i don't want you to put the kid's life
at stake you strip away all the dignity
of a parent
looking at their child i'm not joking
about this imagine being a parent
looking at a child
and you can't afford
you have no house to borrow against you
have no savings
it's wrong
but all the things in that bill
are going to reduce prices
and costs for middle class and working
class people
it's going to reduce
their
cost what what's inflation having to pay
more than the money you have because
things have gone up
well bring down all those costs across
the board from child care to a child
care tax credit
but i'm not supposed to be having this
press conference
[Music]
mr president did senator manchin break
his commitment to you when you announce
the framework the white house says that
all 50 senators were believed to get
behind it all with the democratic
senators so did senator manchin break
his commitment to you
senator manchin i'm going to get
something done thank you